[Music]
darling I need you call me again how we
first met oh you know The Boy Meets Girl
Girl Meets Boy
fall desperately in love hey
[Music]
talk 84 was ambushed
John and Clyde was seen traveling up the
United States I think it's romantic now
to lunatics on a cross-country Kill Tour
this could get messy that would be
awesome
oh God oh God oh
that's disgusting man you always get the
peers
there is a secret depository called the
cash room the casino it transports
everything there and anything off the
books
[Music]
Johnny
here it goes Clyde and I take out the
gods handle is gonna crack the safe
gonna get in we get the money and we
live happily ever after do y'all even
have guns
that'll do nicely
I think we'll be fine
hey guys
why are you like that are you scared
of course not